hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that happened today in the
Bandra blitz club and just twenty four
its Magnus Carlsen with the white beast
against Neil's Grande alias and as a
Carlson said in the in the industry that
it's we have this ridiculous situation
of a Norwegian playing a Swede and we're
both speaking English which is somewhat
unusual I imagine as both of both of
their languages are well they're not not
exactly the easiest of languages but
okay I mentioned in the previous video
that I do have some well joyous news so
here it is as there are pretty much well
pretty much all of the tournaments are
canceled in 2020
today they published that the
Grantchester canceled all of their
events for 2020 so there will be no
events of the Grantchester and it
continues in 2021
but Magnus announced on Twitter that he
is organizing the biggest online chess
tournament ever it's the so called there
you have it the Magnus Carlsen
Invitational it's 250 thousand dollars
prize fund super tournament with eight
top players I don't know if it's exactly
eight top or maybe eight of the top 20
or something like that
and he didn't specify anywhere will he
actually be playing I imagine he will
but it wasn't I don't think it was
mentioned anywhere and it's gonna start
April 18th
so in 16 days and it's gonna last for
four seven days as it will be seven
rounds a single round-robin and there
you have it this is a historic moment
for chess and given that it's possible
to continue top professional play in an
online environment we have not only the
opportunity but the responsibility the
players and fans around the world who
need a distraction and when no other
life competitive sport is being played
there we have it so it's gonna be it's
gonna be awesome
as there are pretty much no events
currently going on and I think this is
only the first of many to come but
getting back to the game cross and in
this game opens with Knight to f3 he
goes for the red team sorry about that
we have c5 baigan Elias
now g3 we have g6 and c3 now slow
playing it with d4 and so on we rush up
to g7 and now we have d4 Knight to f6
and the bishop to g2 so both players
feeling get to their Kings side with
castles and now cousin says that okay if
you're offering me upon our I'm gonna
capture it so D captures on c5 and of
course if you don't want to allow b4 to
solidify the position a 5 now keeping an
eye on b4 Carlsen castles and this is a
new move now so already as a move 7 it's
a completely new game with Knight to a
spec sigmund alias precursor to grab
back his pawn and now Bishop to e3
defending it we have Knight to g4 now
threatening to double up both not only
the C pawns but also add the e pawns so
push up to d4 offering a trade of dark
square Bishop c5 and now of course as
the bishop has no normal good squares h3
now we have ecad for Sundy for H CalPERS
on g4 d captures on c3 Knight captures
and now Knight captures on c5 black
regained his pawn and we have this
position where cross and spawn structure
is a little messed up but he has to
point Islands gonna Daly says three so
it's it's a trade off and he goes for g5
as the the pawn on g4 might might become
a weakness at some point so the six
procuring term develop the light square
bishop also d6 could be an issue for
black with Queen to d2 now with further
defense of the g5 point and also
preparing to bring the rook sin to the
game
rook to b8 the candelas prepares b5 and
rook F to d1 now threatening to pick up
the d6 pawn with b5 now and cousin does
not go after the phone he just starts
improving his pieces we have night to d4
sorry that's not the correct
night-nights the d4 the other night
coming to d5 and now Bishop to d7
we have Knight to d5 and rook to e8 and
already here our constants position is
is very good he has two excellently
placed Knights here the queen is coming
to four which is his next move Queen to
f4
and already there are some threats of
knife to have six check where black will
have to give up the dark square bishop
and it could be a bit dangerous so here
point is if you go Bishop to e5 then a
white can still go for this Knight to f6
check and now Queen will capture and
after G captures the Bishop captures an
F for leaving Carlsen with a triple F
pawn but with with definitely a playable
position so if anything even even white
can be better here as f5 is coming so
not really not really a problem but
instead Green Day Lewis went for rook
the e5 keeping an eye just on everything
also putting pressure on the g5 for now
and now Carlsen just goes Knight to f6
with check we have Bishop Catherine's on
f6 G captures on f6 cause I mentioned in
the stream that he hopes that this pawn
survives long enough to stir some
trouble in blacks camp but a green
village so of course is not going to
make it easy for him he goes g5 he kicks
away the Queen and now it's possible to
go back with the Queen cousin even
mentions this briefly in the stream that
probably Queen d2 is just the best but
it's too much fun not capture the rook
on e5 and for this decision we are
awarding Magnus the morphe head so there
you have it Carson gets the morphe head
and the game continues he goes for Queen
captures on e5 and what's happening here
why why did he give up the Queen well he
captures on e5 by black and now Knight
the c6 putting pressure on the Queen the
rook of course you cannot capture as the
due to the pin Knights the e7 check is
an idea in some lines and it's just it's
just gonna win back some material so
point is do you would do defend the rook
or do you play Queen captures on f6 in
the game of Queen captures and f6 was
played but Queen to c7 is also very
interesting as we get a knight captures
rook Queen captures night and now rook a
to see one threatening just eliminate
the defender of the d7 Bishop so after
Queen to a7 or any move you're still
gonna capture and after Queen captures
you're gonna capture on d7 and you get
this position where it's Queen against
the rook and the bishop but it's not
easy
black plus with the de-spawn here white
threatening checkmate you have to play
Queen b6 regarding this and now it's
it's a well Bishop to b5 will have to be
played going after the f7 pawn and after
captures just captures and you go into
this King and pawning him after all this
madness where black has a bit more
active King but all and all after g4
should be should be something of a draw
so Knight the c6 really are complicated
the move especially for for a 3-minute
blitz game and here we have Queen
captures and f6 instead by grant Ellis
he gives up the rook on b8 and goes for
a different idea with Knight captures on
b8 and Bishop to e6 now so this is this
is the line he prefers rook a to c1
going after the night and now Knight to
a4 so it's a bit of a different bit of a
different everything in that game black
shouldn't have any problems but here
it's it's not at all clear what's
happening here across and one goes for
Knight to d7 he attacks the Queen Queen
to e7 now with a double attack on the
night and now b3 attacking the knight
and here what do you do you cannot move
the knight as well it doesn't really
have all that many good squares but the
problem is what do you play Bishop
captures and d7 is definitely best here
because now you have to capture the
night if you go look to see 7 here then
the night just wiggles out nice to be
610 defends the bishop and after Bishop
h3 adding a third attacker against the
bishop on d7 now Queen d8 defense but
also attacks the rook forces you to
capture with the rook
so after okay seven Queen b8 the Queen
follows the rook and now you're gonna
have to give up the rook captures
captures and captures and again you have
a queen against the rook and Bishop but
here it's a bit more promising for for
black so like I said after Bishop
captures and b7 you would have to go for
B captures on a4 and then wait for for
white to recapture now the thread is
rook c7 to go after the bishop so you
have to play something like this give up
the pawn and then after characters the
game just continues to where it's due to
rooks and Bishop against the Queen and
the bishop still anything can happen as
it is a three minute
blades game so here Grendel is instead
of capturing which is definitely the
best idea goes for Knights to be to puts
pressure on the rook and now look the d2
by Carlson attacking the knight and now
again it's not it's not easy to play
because now if the ship characters nb7
now you play rook to c7 you will win
back the bishop and the knight is trap
the knight has nowhere to go
so whatever black plays before let's say
you're gonna win the bishop captures
here and after the Queen moves you're
gonna deliver a check and pick up the
knight unbe - and then it's going to be
two rooks and the bishop against the
Queen of course much better for white so
Grandal is instead went Queen to a3 the
guard the night and now Magnus went for
Knight to c5 it's a similar idea he
wants them he wants to prevent the
Bishop captures night and then deal with
the night and beat you but there is an
even more forcing line so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this well idea that it's it's a bit too
elusive for a three minute
let's game but you are comfortable in
your own home so maybe maybe you want to
give it a shot well I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations I'm
spotting the this instant winning idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's Knight to f6 width check King has
to move now there's no longer the threat
of rush of characters 97 but the
difference between this and mark
Magnus's move is that this comes with
checks so next one we're going to just
play rook c2 and win the night as the
knight has nowhere to go so at least
King g7 you go after the knight Knight
delivers check again you again go after
tonight and now Knight the c7 so
basically similar to what cost and
achieved but his night is on c5 but it
is a bit different because now to
prevent rook to c2 you have to go Bishop
a5 but now efore just kicks away the
bishop bishop here and now you just win
the knight and the white will have well
- too much material and in the winning
advantage however magnus played night
the c5 which seems like a similar idea
the knight on c5 instead of on c7 but
it's actually not here and Elias had the
option of going Bishop to 5 keeping an
eye
the C 2 square and after E for now he
would have Knight to c4 but of course
impossible to spot with with in a
three-minute blitz game now you just
well the rook is under attack so you
have to do something about that and also
this rock is under attack so you have to
do something about that and there is not
much you can do after rook to the 8th
check King g7 you will either you will
win this night hunter Luke also has to
be moved so you will you will just
wiggle out of your problems
however Greendale is play tonight the
Knights the c4 immediately without the
inclusion of Bishop to f5 but now it's a
bit different because now rook to b8
check by Magnus King to g7 and now
Knight captures an e6 width check that's
the problem now that the king is in g7f
characters on e6 and now of course not
captures as the rook is hanging looked
the c2 we have night back the b6 now by
grand alias and now comes looked the c7
width check King to h6 and now of course
Bishop to c4 threatening just to gobble
up that h7 pawn which will result in
checkmate so g4 making an escape route
for the King but here Magnus just plays
rook the g8 now taking away the g g5
square from the black king and next move
he's just going to deliver Queen to h7
rookie actress on h7 checkmate and that
there is nothing you can do about this
there are no tricks there are no checks
Quincy one check is not possible as the
rock covers that square so that's that's
pretty much it
so after work the g8 to Greendale is
resigned the game and this wonderful
wonderful victory was achieved by Magnus
Carlsen just just beautiful stuff that
Queen captures on e5 move we can see it
once again in slow motion
so g5 was played and then Queen captures
on e5 just just outstanding they're
deserving over morphe head so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said looking forward to the TD
Invitational two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for an online
tournament definitely a lot of money and
we'll the we'll see how it goes should
be a lot of fun I would like to thank
Henry Nero Stein and Manuel Martinez
Matias Chris Mark David Stone and beat
hanga for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world which is pretty much
online at the moment thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day